okay so
this month we're
going to take a look at
a just a brief introduction
to
programming the gpu with cuda and thrust
now this is not the only way to program
a gpu
i will just mention that there's
opencl
but this presentation is about cuda
so
cuda is
specific to nvidia hardware i'm not
aware of any
um vendor of other gpus that provides a
cuda implementation i've heard of uh
cuda translator layers that people sell
but i'm not familiar with those so we're
not gonna say anything more about it
uh cuda is supported by nvidia on linux
and windows
and
this talk is an introduction only cuda
is a very
broad and deep topic and i'm only a
novice cuda programmer i am by no means
a
cuda expert i did run this by
one of my co-workers who i do consider
to be a cuda expert and
he didn't uh point out anything
blatantly wrong but if there is anything
wrong in here it's my fault and nobody
else's
uh so um
the gpu or graphics processing unit has
been around on the pc for quite a long
time so they started out as just you
know the cga card or an ega card or vga
card or super vga card etc
all those acronyms referring to
the geometry in terms of pixels of the
display
that was supported and you know usually
the number of bits of color per pixel
and so on
but basically all these systems had one
thing in common which is
the display memory used by the graphics
hardware is just
part of the memory address space of the
machine so you just manipulate the frame
buffer like you're manipulating memory
and then and that was fine for dos um
dos didn't have a huge
device abstraction but when windows came
along
they now had an abstract api that
represented how you manipulated the
frame buffer you no longer manipulated
the frame buffer by just reading and
writing raw memory that was
reserved for the device driver
so the next
piece of acceleration to come along were
so-called fixed function accelerators
and these are
pieces of dedicated hardware that
perform the various graphics operations
as defined by the windows api initially
and then later they start accelerating
the 3d graphics apis opengl at first and
then directx
and somewhere in there was also a
proprietary vendor-specific api called
glide
all of these ended up with
acceleration paths for the graphics
processing unit where it could now
accept commands
and operate on those commands instead of
just
acting as dumb memory with pixels inside
around the 2000s uh beginning with
directx 8
was the first version of directx to
introduce this and i believe that the
opengl version
supporting shaders came out around the
same time
um we got programmable shader blocks
these were
initially assembly
instruction coded blocks and then
eventually became
programmable in a higher level c like
language
the
directx variant was called high level
shader language hlsl and the opengl
variant was called gl shader language
glso and they were
largely identical
and the reason these two apis track each
other and functionality is because
they're actually not tracking each other
they're tracking the hardware so as the
hardware evolves each api supports the
new hardware features
and this led to
the ability for the first time to
in a
well even let me back up a second even
with a fixed function accelerator
as the fixed function accelerators got
fancier with more
options and controls and data paths
available to them it was possible to do
a style of general purpose computation
as long as your problem matched a very
specific
set of constraints in the parallelism
namely you had to be able to take your
problem and turn it into some kind of
pixel representation and then do a pixel
operation
as part of your computation and then
read the pixels back and map that back
into your
problem domain so with even with fixed
function accelerators you could sort of
do general purpose computation but it
was very restricted
once you got programmable shader blocks
then
even though you're still operating
within this fiction of a graphics
pipeline and i say fiction because
you're not really interested in
producing an image what you're
interested in doing is performing some
kind of computation on a regular grid
which is
a process that you can do in graphics by
simply drawing a rectangle that covers
the whole screen that guarantees that
the per pixel shader runs for every
pixel on the screen and
you can also do some tricks where
the attributes that you attach to this
rectangle that you drew on the screen
get interpolated across the screen and
they can become input parameters to your
shader blocks
however it's still
trying to do general purpose computation
by fitting
this square peg of general purpose
computation into the round hole of
these shader blocks provided by
graphics pipelines
in november 2006
cuda introduced was introduced by nvidia
and cuda
completely disconnects you from
the graphics pipeline
and lets you just program
the gpu function units
without having to pretend that it's a
vertex shader or a pixel shader or
you know somehow doing operations with
textures as inputs
you can just give up all of that and
deal directly with
gpu processing
in a general purpose manner without
even
writing a single opengl call for
instance or a single directx call or
calling any library that calls any of
those
functions
so that's leads us to where we are now
and
so what is cuda it is
stands for the compute unified device
architecture
it's for general purpose
parallel processing not just graphics
the um
abstraction
exposed by cuda is to think of the gpu
as a very powerful coprocessor to the
cpu
and you write c plus code directly you
don't write in one of these weird shader
languages or any some kind of other
language you write in c plus
so
why would you want to use cuda well the
um
the gpu provides
a very different
performance point than the cpu
and if you've got an nvidia gpu in your
system
and you're processing
large amounts of data or
the amount of processing that you have
to perform is very compute intensive
it could be that
using these cuda cores
can make a big difference in how your
application performs
um and given that we can just program it
in c plus plus it's not
too far afield from what we're already
doing for
software running on the cpu
and here's a little
diagram i found
illuminating from the cuda toolkit
so on the cpu
the silicon budget
the transistors within the chip that are
devoted to specific tasks
are much more fun focused on
running a few
relatively speaking threads that are
able to be switched out at a moment's
notice for other threads you know they
may block on complex i o and so on and
the cpu is more targeted in terms of
transistor real estate towards running a
few threads and being able to switch
them a lot
whereas in the gpu
the
real estate of the transistors is more
dedicated to having more cores
but they
um
they run in
uh
an environment where they're not
switched as often the context switch
doesn't happen as much as it does on the
the cpu and they're actually the
individual cores are actually weak
compared to a cpu core but they managed
to outpower the cpu by having so many of
them and being able to operate
on
memory in a fashion that's that can be
faster than the cpu so
um
cuda gives you a
an abstraction of the hardware so you
don't
typically write anything that is you
know a direct assembly language for the
particular gpu that you have you write
in c plus
and
to interact with the
unique characteristics of the hardware
and the gpu namely the fact that it's a
big parallel grid of processors
the
hardware is exposed as a set of
abstractions of a hierarchy of thread
groups
a hierarchy of shared memories
and
synchronization parameters that allow
you to coordinate the threads that are
operating in parallel
and
there is both fine-grained data
parallelism and thread parallelism
but those
are uh
that fine-grained parallelism is
orchestrated in as a small block of
threads
and those blocks are nested within
coarse-grained data parallelism and task
parallelism across the entire device
so the approach is you take your problem
you subdivide it into into sub problems
that can be all solved independently
and then you
take those
results they were all
computed independently and combined them
into the into the final result
so it's um
it's a dividing conquer approach
essentially
and
those uh sub-problems can be solved by
threads that are cooperating by
interacting with the same
piece of shared memory between those
threads
whereas the course problems are all
being computed independently of each
other and they're not interacting
at all
except maybe you aggregated on the on
the host
so um here's just a visualization of
that that your problem space is this
grid that's shown here in green
and you take your grid
divide that up into a bunch of chunks
each one is a block and then within each
block there's a bunch of
collaborating threads within a block
so the blocks here are the
subproblems given the subdivision of the
problem if you run on different gpus
the gpus have
streaming multiprocessors in them that
can accept blocks and schedule blocks
onto the threads that are inside the sms
so you carve up your problem into blocks
and depending on the
size and number of the sms on your gpu
they get scheduled automatically
by the driver and then you get an
answer when they're all done however
however that takes place however it's
partitioned among the sms
and um
it's possible that
if your blocks are small relative to the
number of threads within the sm multiple
blocks can be scheduled onto a single sm
and this is fine because remember all
these blocks represent the parts of the
problem that can be solved independently
of each other so exactly what order and
how they get scheduled onto the gpu
doesn't matter all we all we're
interested in is finding out when
they're all done
the
hierarchy of
memory
in a gpu
is just as important for
your
final performance as the hierarchy of
memory is on your cpu right so if you
have an algorithm
that runs on the cpu
and its data memory access pattern is
such that the the data being accessed
can't all fit in your data cache
you're going to find your program runs a
lot slower
if it has to process a large amount of
data
if you can reorganize that memory access
pattern so that
the
accesses are more coherent
then you will get more cash hits and
then you'll get the get the data to the
cpu faster than if you're experiencing
cash misses
and so in the gpu the same thing is true
there's obviously there's registers that
each thread has each thread has its own
set of registers
so
it doesn't share registers with other
threads within the same block
each thread has its own registers
and then there is local memory
that is exclusive to that particular
thread
and then with between the threads in a
block
there is a group of shared memory that
can be used for
these threads to cooperate and solve the
sub problem so if you
if you have a so-called trivially or
embarrassingly parallel algorithm where
there's no communication needed between
adjacent elements in order to get things
done then great you don't even need
shared memory you can just do everything
in embarrassingly parallel fashion but
most interesting problems have some sort
of interaction between adjacent elements
or between
elements within a block
you know elements in your sub problem in
order to compute the
the answer for the sub problem
so um
after
the threads local memory the next
fastest memory is the shared memory that
is available to
threads in a block and then after
that
you've got global memory the global
memory is the slowest
but
at some point you know the data has to
get in from
the global memory into
your
thread that is computing the result
so
in the
toolkit
they go through an example where they
show how they increase the performance
of their implementation
by
taking a chunk of the global memory that
they read once and copying it into the
shared memory between threads where it's
read multiple times in the course of
computing the answer
and that resulted in a performance
improvement because the shared memory is
faster access time for the threads in
that block
there's also constant and texture memory
spaces constant memory
is
um
handy for
bits of data that don't change during
the execution of any of the threads but
might change every time you
um invoke code on the gpu
but they're not changing for the
duration of
waiting for some gpu computation to
complete so constant memory can be
useful for that it can
take pressure off shared memory or
it it is also faster than global memory
so it's a good place to put values that
don't change as you're computing
texture memory spaces
um
they have special units that um
are in the graphics pipeline that do
texture processing
and this can be useful for uh
if you have to do interpolating style
sampling of a regular grid of values
this is something that the texture units
do
already by themselves so you can sample
the texture
from
floating point coordinates so you get
interpolation between discrete values
within the grid
your grid of
values whether it is they are
pixel pixels picture elements or whether
they are just data values it doesn't
really matter as far as the texture
hardware is concerned
so that can be useful to access that
texture memory space along with the
texture processing
which you can do
okay so
what is the
concept of
how this works so there is
um
as we said that the host is basically
using the gpu as a coprocessor and
typically your host code will go through
a loop until your
computation is finished or maybe it's an
interactive application in which case
you know it just goes through this loop
forever
where you
have some data that comes from the host
and is sent down to
the device the gpu
you run some code on the gpu to get some
kind of analysis of that data performed
and usually you
get the data back on the host now if
you're just going to keep
some kind of interactive application you
know on a machine where you're
displaying the results graphically
perhaps or something um
maybe you don't need to send the data
back to the host it's not required that
you do that it's just this is a common
data flow for a lot of applications
device code is the code that is running
on the gpu and this is
looked at from the point of view of host
code of running a kernel and it's
basically a function call
and it is executed the code
that is in the kernel
the the function that is the kernel
rather
is the code that is executed by all the
threads
on the gpu so it is a so-called single
instruction multi multiple threads style
execution as opposed to uh single
instruction multiple data
and that's because um
in a simple scenario
an individual data element can't uh that
or the processing assigned to an
individual element in the multiple data
part
it's all the same instructions so
you can't have
divergent execution
across the elements whereas within sim t
which is multiple threads the threads
can process an if
statement and one thread takes the true
branch and the other thread takes the
else branch
there's a bunch of details you can read
in the toolkit documentation about how
this looks from the point of view of the
hardware implementation
it's still just kind of a high level
view
um and device code has access to all the
device resources directly and this
includes special data types that are
implemented in the functional units of
the gpu that aren't implemented in host
code
things like 16 bit floating point values
there's values in special
graphics related formats
there's also the different memory types
are directly accessible as we said
before that there's constant memory
texture memory shared memory global
memory
you can also interoperate with graphics
apis so
if your goal is to do some
parallel computation and then visualize
the results
it's not necessary to copy the results
back to the host just so you can get
them back into the graphics card for
display so you can interoperate
directly with the graphics apis and have
a resource that is shared by the
graphics api and by cuda so that
cuda can either read or write
from this resource and the graphic
system can then treat it as an input
like a texture or something
the um
typical way that you would program cuda
is to use the so-called runtime api
and this gives you
just a bunch of function calls to let
you manipulate resources on the device
allocate memory deallocate memory
schedule a thread for launch and so on
there's also a math api that gives you a
lot of the standard math functions
so these can be considered
built into cuda itself as opposed to
being provided by an external compiler
it's mostly
a a convenience for
um
when you do dynamic compiling of cuda
code and load that dynamically into the
gpu instead of just at the time you
build your application
you might have
you know templated gpu code that changes
based on the user's options and
you want to take that code and
compile it at the time you're running
the application that is certainly
possible with cuda
there's also a large number of
middleware libraries
basic linear algebra subroutines
jpeg codec fast fourier transform
now they just
recently
gave a presentation on this
implementation of the c plus plus
standard library for
c plus on the gpu in cuda
i haven't looked at
that in detail so i don't know to what
extent
the standard library is available
i would expect it's going to be
the
iterators containers and
algorithms portion that they're
concerned with
not things like formatted io and stuff
like that
um this is ram high quality random
number generation if you ever do any
stuff in cryptography or
encryption then
having a high quality random number
generator implementation is important
um also dealing with sparse matrices or
image or signal processing
we me i mentioned the runtime
compilation is supported through a an
additional library
and there's a linear system solver
there's and these are just libraries
that come with the cuda toolkit there
are hundreds if not thousands of
libraries built on top of
cuda or these
libraries that come with cuda toolkit
itself
so
what does this look like to program this
well you get some language extensions
and the language extensions allow you to
mix
device code and host code in the same
file
so it's not like
you have a magic
build system rule that says files with
this certain extension like cpp get they
get compiled with the host compiler and
then
maybe you've got gpp
files and they get compiled with the
device
compiler
in cuda the philosophy is that stuff can
be all mixed together in the same file
and actually the file extension doesn't
really
mean much in terms of the compiler
itself
it
obviously
automatic pattern matching build rules
and stuff care about the extensions that
you use
but um
you
have your grid of blocks that represents
your sub problems to be solved
and you have the dimensions of the
blocks containing
how many threads are going to be
cooperating to solve the sub problem
and
those
dimensions can be specified for these
kernel functions with this triple
chevron syntax
and that just makes it easy to
configure a
gpu launch of code
and get back
you know
the result from that computation
given a
specific grid and block configuration
and
really it's just syntactic sugar for
turning that notation into a bunch of
api calls to configure the gpu
uh launch parameters and launch the
kernel and so on so it makes it simpler
but
if for whatever reason
you need to go lower it's possible but
there's not really any gain from from
doing that so
fortunately the simple and
straightforward thing is the is is also
the recommended thing
um so this happens by way of the mvcc
compiler driver
this is the thing that takes your source
files first and
transforms them into
uh standard c plus plus that then is fed
on to the native compiler on your
machine
and it generates mvcc
while it's processing your code if it
finds device code that runs on the
device
it compiles that
into the gpu assembly language that's
used
and
it is stripped out from
the source code that is seen by the
native compiler so that it ends up as a
build output but
it's not seen after mvcc processes it it
doesn't get passed along to the host
compiler which is used only for host
code at that point
so
you
could program the gpu directly in its
abstract assembly language which is
called ptx which is a defined
instruction set you can go and look at
the
documentation supplied by nvidia
when you um
[Music]
normally just tell it to
tell your
build system to you know just compile
with nvcc
it may select a
targeted uh
streaming multiprocessor version
and sm version it may say like you know
sm50 or something
and
that's
taking the cuda code that has to run on
the device
and compiling it to a specific
architecture
and
that may not be desirable because you
may want to take advantage of
improvements in
the
um
mvcc compiler or take advantage of
improvements in the
the ptx compiler
and
you can instead when you compile with
mvcc you can just generate ptx instead
of
sm version specific
uh binary files that are called kubens
either mvcc can generate the kubens or
it can generate the
so-called you know version list ptx
and that gives you a way if you're
generating ptx it gives you a way of
kind of feature proofing
your application so that if new
shader or sorry not shader model but
streaming multi-processor instruction
set versions come out
then the generic ptx can be
jit compiled to target that gpu pa in a
possibly more efficient manner um i
think what most people do though is
they
select the
versions that they want to
support um
i see there's a question in the chat
we'll get to that in a second the the
versions that you want to support
can be cooked into the your build
process so that when
the user is running on the version that
you support it just directly loads that
binary into the gpu and there's no
translation happening
you can combine that with the ptx
approach to give you the the future
proofing by
having both the ptx and the kubin in
your executable and then if the version
that the user has doesn't match any of
the versions that you targeted
specifically it'll fall back to the
generic ptx
and the question is from the chat is uh
by host code am i referring to code that
runs on the cpu and the answer is yes
you will see this when we look at an
example in a second i think it will
become more clear
so in
the c language they've added extensions
for specifying
execution space specifiers
uh let's say whether this code is going
to run as a kernel that's the global
whether it's going to run only on the
host or only on the device and then
memory space specifiers that allow you
to specify
you know a variable is attached to a
particular memory space
on the gpu
you also have
built into the language and not supplied
by a header file
you have
vector types
that are commonly used on
gpu-oriented
processing because the
the functional units in the gpu are not
necessarily
although they can be used to process
scalar values
they're
usually arranged as a four wide vector
so operating on
one two three or four wide
data quantities as a single
data type is
preferred
there's also built-in variables that
tell you the
dimensions of the grid the dimensions of
blocks
which block you are in and which thread
within the block you are in
and the warp size
um
most of the time you won't need to worry
about warp size if if you need to know
what one or sorry if you want to see
about warps i would recommend reading
the toolkit documentation on it a warp
is
a measure of scheduling in terms of how
well your blocks fit to
the
computational units in the streaming
multiprocessors
um there's also built-in functions for
synchronization between threads because
as we said that within a block
the threads are operating cooperatively
to solve the sub-problems
so here is
this is lifted straight from the
cuda toolkit samples this is just an
example of taking
uh two one-dimensional vectors that are
inputs
adding them together to produce another
one-dimensional vector that is the
output
so here is
the function that is our kernel vec add
it's i it's a kernel function by virtue
of the fact that it's decorated with
that double underscore global
and we are using the global variables
block dim and block index and thread
index
to identify
which of the
input elements in these vectors that
this particular kernel is going to
execute on so remember we are doing
single instruction multiple thread
so each thread
is running this vec add function
and what you want to do is divide the
work among all the threads
and we've done that in
a two level hierarchy of blocks and
threads within blocks
so to get the particular index for this
thread
it's just one dimensional so we're only
using the x component of these variables
taking which block we're in multiplying
that by the size of the block index or
the block dimension rather
and then adding
our thread index
as an offset into that chunk of data
defined by the blocks
host memory allocated in the normal
fashion with
malloc
the device memory is allocated with cuda
and then we can copy from
the host memory to the device memory to
get the inputs onto the gpu
then we can launch our kernel this vec
ad and you see the triple chevron syntax
there that
allows us to specify the dimensions of
the blocks and the
the dimensions of the grid
so the number of blocks in the grid and
their organization of sorry the
organization of blocks in the grid in
this case it's one-dimensional
and the number of threads per block
then finally we have to get the data off
of the gpu and onto the host
so we can do something with it or
examine it
and that's pretty much
um
the standard flow for
doing gpu computation in that way we can
look at
okay so here is
let me make this font a little bigger
for you
so um
in cmake
they added cuda language support
quite some time ago
so we don't need to do anything special
to tell it um
how to process cuda source files we just
have to name them with dot cu and
when we do add executable
and the source files listed in there
cmake will figure out that it needs to
run
mvcc on those files
so this is just straight copy and pasted
from
the toolkit sample
vector add
so we've got
this is just a little helper file file
from the toolkit this is the
um
sorry this is a helper file from the
toolkit samples
this cuda runtime is the
header file that you would use
in your application
here's our
kernel that we saw my intellisense
doesn't work so great with cuda so
that's why there are some things in red
there's actually nothing wrong with this
code
so we are
allocating code allocating memory on the
host for the inputs and the outputs
initializing the inputs with a bunch of
random numbers
allocating space on the device for the
input vectors and the output vector
getting the data from the host to the
device
for the two input vectors and then
launching the kernel
and then copying the data from
the device to the host and then
doing a little sanity check on it so if
we run this program
it copied the data over it launched the
kernel it copied the data back the
answer back and it checked the values
and they all look like they computed
correctly
so
um using it from cmake pretty simple
there is one i will show you the
top level cmake here
it's not required but you can specify
for a project
what
languages you are going to use in that
project
and excuse me
it's not required but you can specify
cuda for your project as one of the
languages that you're using
um
i do
find package to locate the cuda runtime
library that i need to link against and
the cuda runtime headers
this stuff here i just added as a way to
conveniently use the
little helper file
helper file header that was used in that
sample that i copied from the cuda
samples
and i set up a
cma convenience for thrust we'll look at
that a little bit later
so
the whole reason we're doing this is
because we're trying to get
concurrency going on to you know
hopefully improve the performance of our
application or maybe
it's just the amount of data we need to
process is so large that the more data
we can operate on the faster we can get
done what we need to do
and
in any system
if you're trying to get concurrency
going it
it can be a bit of a problem because
with concurrency always implies
possible
problems due to sharing of data
and coordination of different processes
happening concurrently
in
cpu land this is you know standard
threads and things like that
and
um
with a cuda application there's an extra
dimension now of this coprocessor
so
we can have
multiple threads on the host that's one
form of concurrency we can have going on
we can have code executing on the gpu so
we've got another form of concurrency
going on
and
these
gpu cards they don't just have
graphics pipelines
and
graphics processing units they also have
memory uh transfer units so direct
memory access units that can transfer
data quickly between the device and the
host
a question in the chat is
that when we looked at this code
let's just go back
to this code we were looking here
there we go
and the question is uh he see some
mallocs in here and he was right they
were in here when we were allocating
host memory
and he says does cuda support c plus
plus style new and delete or maybe it
doesn't matter because this would be
host code and the answer is
in
host code you can use new delete
whatever you want to use in this
particular example the
example this particular example in the
cuda sdk is written in more of a c style
but so that's why they're using malloc
but malloc is not necessary here
this is host memory you can get it any
way
yeah
you want to
down here when we allocated the device
memory with cuda malloc
that is the only way to get device
memory allocated
and device memory is allocated on the
host
in terms of
sorry
that's not the right way to say it
device memory is allocated by the host
it is not on the host it is on the
device
but the
function calls that allocate that memory
and carve it up are done on the host
so memory allocation is essentially
a gpu configuration step
not a gpu
execution step
um
i believe that they've
got some constrained scenarios where
threads running on the gpu could call
cuda malloc but i i'm don't quote me on
that that could be just a mistake on my
part
it's very unusual to do that though
right because normally
what you're allocating on the gpu
is scratch pad work areas input buffers
and output buffers
and
for scratch pad buffers
obviously
registers are the best
thread local storage is the next best
and then shared memory is the next best
and then global memory
is what you would be allocating when you
run the function calls on the host
so
the slowest one
is what you get from this cuda malloc
um
but basically all the memory allocation
is happening by a result of function
calls on the host and however you get
your host memory is
up to you could be shared memory segment
could be a memory map file could be
anything
cuda doesn't care because it's only used
as the source or target of copy
operations
um there is advanced usages where you
can have a shared address space between
the cpu and the host but i'm sorry
between the cpu and the gpu
but we're not going to go into that
depth because this is introduction so um
as i was saying
you've got the execution that is
obviously happening concurrently
but it can also have these copy
operations in flight
um between
cpu
or i guess host memory and device memory
or device memory and host memory or
device 2 device you can have copy
operations in flight in parallel
with the execution of
kernels in the blocks
so
we mentioned that it's code on the host
that is running as doing these memory
allocations it is doing the kernel
launches and it's doing these memory
copy operations
if you want to get the maximum amount of
concurrency
what you really need to do is
arrange everything
as a bunch of asynchronous operations
that are happening in a well-defined
order
but we don't care about when they
complete in terms of
the intermediate steps we just are
waiting for the final result
to come back to us however those
intermediate steps may have constraints
relative to each other
such that
they have to happen
in a certain order even though they've
been scheduled concurrently
so in order to manage that the
cuda api provides something called a
stream and
it is basically just a command fifo and
a command q
and
the commands within the stream are
executed in the order that they were
submitted to the stream
and that means that if
one of the commands needs something to
happen before it can start it waits
until that condition has been satisfied
before that command starts
this is how you can combine
kernel launches
with
memory copies
so that
the
copies and the kernels could potentially
overlap if they're on different streams
and as long as the
kernel doesn't need a copy to complete
they can proceed independent of each
other
so this question in the chat said is
there a way to map cuda results to
pixels
and you can do that directly with
interop
functions in the gra that allow cuda to
interoperate with opengl or direct3d
that you could have the output of your
computation
be a pixel surface or you know a
two-dimensional grid of pixels an image
a texture what have you
in the graphics api so you can just
storing into your output buffer results
in
modifying this resource that's used in
the graphics pipeline
it's really easy to do that it basically
looks from your device code it looks
like you have a pointer to the pixel
memory and you are just writing directly
into it
another question is
is that a typical stack cuda opengl
let's take a look at this link here
oh it's
the link's been sanitized and it's not
working for me because
webex has got the windows all covered up
not just basically cuda sample
egl interrupt
if it's just the sample from the sdk
then yeah it's exactly what it
um
okay so streams are how you can manage
the
concurrency uh between
different kernels so within a kernel
you're managing the current concurrency
by
dividing up the problem into a grid of
blocks
processing those blocks and combining
the block results
however um it's not always the case that
everything you need to do is coming from
just one kernel right you may have to
launch a bunch of different kernels that
do different things depending on
the results or depending on your
scenario
so you can orchestrate multiple kernels
relative to each other
either in a single stream or using
multiple streams
and
typically you're going to have
additional memory copy events going on
to coordinate those events or coordinate
those kernels as well
now for different streams
to coordinate with each other
you can use events so you have you
basically can record an event onto a
stream and then have another stream
wait until that event was recorded
and that allows you to orchestrate the
relative ordering of different streams
that are operating concurrently in order
to solve your whole problem
the
thrust library
is a c template library that is similar
to the standard library in terms of the
algorithms and containers portions
algorithms iterators and containers
portion of the standard library
and
gives you vector-like containers for
data on the host or data on the device
and the iterators from these containers
understand
which
kind of memory they're attached to
and they give you algorithms
that can operate
in host code or they can operate in
device code and it it works fine either
way
now generally with an algorithm in order
to do something interesting
most of the time the interesting part
comes from your own computation that you
want to do over a sequence
or on values within a sequence
and
you do that you know with the standard
library algorithms by supplying a
function object
um
also called a functor
and basically this is
summed up in modern c plus plus by just
using a lambda
because that's
as we
saw in our presentation on lambdas that
lambdas basically are just syntactic
sugar for compiler generated function
objects for you
so
they provide some simple functors in
this thrust functional header
like you know the plus operator
producing a
a functor that you know takes two values
adds them together returns the sum
but you can also just write a uh device
decorated lambda to do whatever
kind of work you need to do within the
application of an algorithm
so thrust gives algorithms for searching
for copying reductions
merging reordering
prefix sums which is a kind of
um
kind of a
an advanced version of accumulate if
you're familiar with the algorithm of
standard accumulate
in the c plus plus standard library
there's a set operation sorting and
transformations now um
we'll take a look at this
in in a second here
but
the
s the cuda c plus plus standard library
effort i think is
uh either overlapping here in in some
senses
um
in that they're providing
i believe standard
library algorithm implementations that
are run on the gpu so they can just be
used from
gpu code
the
thrust code is more oriented towards
something that looks like you're running
an algorithm from the standard library
and it turns into launching a kernel on
the device
with
the inputs um
copied over to
the gpu
and the kernel runs the algorithm on the
device and then the output is
written back to
either the gpu or it's written back to
the host or what have you
so here is that same add vector sample
that i took
when we looked at it before it was using
the runtime api directly
and i just copy and pasted that i didn't
make any modifications to it at all
here what i've done is i've converted it
to use thrust to do the exact same thing
so here
we have the thrust host vector class so
this represents a dynamically resizable
array of t
in host memory
so i'm creating my two host input
vectors here
and i'm initializing them using the
generate algorithm from this the
standard library
so i'm just taking that lambda and i am
running it over
every element in those two sequences and
generating new values to be
stored
in those sequences
next i'm going to allocate
some
device memory
with the device vector class
and i'm using the copy constructor
so what thrust does is it says oh
you're allocating
a chunk of memory on the device
and you're initializing it with a chunk
of memory that's on the host so what i
will do is call cuda malloc to get the
appropriate amount of device memory for
the size that this vector needs to be to
accept that input
and then i will
call
cuda mem copy to copy the host data to
the newly allocated deviced
array so i do that for the two
device input vectors
and then
for the
device output vector i just need to have
it appropriately sized so in that case
it will do the cuda malloc to get the
device memory allocated but it doesn't
do a copy because it it's just a
a uh
default constructed t in the
allocated memory right when you when you
use this form of
the constructor of stood vector
that takes a size
it's not specifying the capacity it's
specifying the size of the vector
so it's not that it can hold num
elements is that it does hold num
elements
and then we're going to invoke the
kernel it's the same as before except
now because our device memory is
represented by these device vector
classes
we need to get the raw pointer out of
there so we can use raw pointer cast
to
get the
address of the zeroth element of those
three vectors
and then finally we need to get the data
back onto
the host i think my
okay that was device memory
a b and c on the device and then
oops
sorry
now that we need to get the device data
copied over onto the host we can create
a host vector initialized by a device
vector and it will allocate the memory
on the host copy the data from the
device to the host
and
we can take a look at what that looks
like
so here
um
same add executable as we did before
and this time i've just said that i
depend on the
the cuda run time
right everything's going to depend on
um actually i could take this out i just
didn't take it out but i'm going to use
thrust and all that's really doing is
just setting up
include search path location because
thrust is a header only library it's
just a convenience in cmake to have an
imported target that knows where those
include directories live so i don't have
to
specify that path explicitly and if i
need to i can configure it using cmake's
configuration interface
so source file
i've stripped out all that helper stuff
we don't need that anymore here's stuff
from
the standard library that i'm using cpus
plus standard library here's the device
factor and host vector that i'm using
from thrust
it's still a cuda file so this
global annotation still applies that's
our kernel that hasn't changed
here's our
allocating the host vectors filling them
out
allocating the device vectors
and the device vector for the output
launching the kernel
getting the data from the device back
over to the host
and running our little check on it so if
we
run this program
visual studio always wants to be in
front
we can see that
it ran the same as before it copied the
results back from the device and
everything agrees with its computation
that it performed on the host
so
i think you know
if i have to
manage this device memory myself i have
to know when i have to
reallocate it to make it larger because
now my input problem size changed et
cetera et cetera i i'd rather have that
inside some kind of vector class
than have to deal with that myself
now
we did
raw pointer cast down here when we
called the kernels
or the kernel
um that's because the kernel just needs
to access this data
it doesn't need to allocate it or resize
it
so that's all been decided by the time
we get here so just dealing with a raw
pointer here these raw pointers in no
way indicate ownership
uh the ownership decisions are made by
the host code that has already run
before this kernel is launched
so that part pretty much stays the same
the
getting the data back and forth
is easier now some people don't like the
they don't like the
fact that you know the the so-called
work is hidden in the constructors and
so on i i think that's the whole point
of an abstraction is to hide work
it doesn't mean you should use these
things in a naive manner and result in
excess of data excessive data copying
either to or from the gpu because
you know it's just not
going to be the way to make things run
as fast as possible
this question in here says is there
support for move semantics between cpu
and gpu and
i believe the answer is not in thrust i
have not looked at the
proposed cuda c plus standard library
i think
from the way that i've seen it uh
pitched which is like a one sentence
summary of a presentation
um that i believe that that
cuda c plus standard library is meant to
be a standard library implementation for
device code entirely anything that's
mixing
address spaces
is going to be happening on the host
um
another question is if there are two
distinct locations one in cpu d-ram and
the other and gpu d-ram i i don't think
move semantics can can optimize that was
a comment i
yeah i mean moving
the only the only thing moving would get
you
is
if you implemented move semantics from
the cpu to the gpu say
it would mean
um you moved it
from host memory to gpu memory that
would just turn into a cuda mem copy
and then the resulting
source vector which was in
host memory space would just now be
empty
so you would lose the host copy and gain
a device copy
i i i don't know that there's
a whole lot of i think advantages of
doing that just advantage would be like
reduction in
cpu dram usage
but yeah well
okay the dirty secret of
memory allocation in a host process is
memory is never returned to the
operating system
so you didn't gain anything that you
didn't you didn't gain anything that you
couldn't gain yourself by just saying
you know host vector dot clear
oh
yeah
if you go look at memory allocators for
instance on on linux or old school you
know it's s break on old school unix
is the thing that you call to obtain
virtual memory from the operating system
in a process
every memory allocator
when it runs out of memory it will ask
more from the operating system but
if the operating system gives it to it
it will never give it back to the
operating system
it is possible to do that but i've never
seen a memory allocator that does do
that
so it just becomes part of the virtual
address space of your host process and
whether you call free or clear doesn't
it it frees up pressure on the allocator
but it doesn't free up
memory all the way if you know what i
mean yeah
but you can just do that yourself by
saying you know you
um copy the host vector into the
destination vector and then you say
hostvector.clear
yeah
i guess.clear isn't quite the same as
moving it
because
in stood vector
clear does not necessarily
release the allocation of the that
represents the capacity of the container
but i believe if you do clear and then
shrink to fit
it does guarantee that
the
memory is released back to at least your
memory allocator
yeah
i mean it gives it back to the allocator
so the next time you call new
that memory is available for that call
to new
but it it it doesn't go away from the
process
back to the operating system it never
goes that far
it you could
have it go that far i've just never
heard of or seen an allocator that
actually does that
that's interesting yeah uh
okay i think we're caught up on
questions
let's see
uh um would
i mean if i am to
use all c plus plus all the way uh do
you think is there any disadvantage
in using
uh thrust device vector of care star for
doing all the allocations or
compared to using malloc coda malloc
explicitly
well
thrust libraries and header only library
so you can you know step through it in
the debugger and see exactly what it's
doing it's basically it's calling cuda
malloc
to get a capacity that it needs
syntactic sugar yeah yeah i mean that's
well that's what stood vector is too
right stood vector
is entirely implemented in a header as
an inline template class
and you can examine the entire
implementation and you will find out
that all it's doing is
new and delete
and mem copy
mem copy when it is suitable
that's an optimization
conceptually it does a mem copy
semantically it
it has to do element by element copy in
order to guarantee that non-trivial
constructors and these structures are
run etc
which by the way
thrust also guarantees
oh nice right i mean i i have a devote
device vector of float in this example
i can just as easily have a device
vector
of a user defined data type where the
constructor does something non-trivial
what will thrust do thrust will call
cuda malloc
to
obtain the raw memory
then it will launch a kernel
that invokes my user-defined constructor
in place on each of the elements
necessary to default construct my
user-defined type
that's awesome
so
it is
obtaining the semantics of a stood
vector
even though the memory that you're
manipulating is on the gpu and in order
to run the constructor for your data
type
on the gpu it has to launch a kernel
that does the things that stood vector
does which is when you
when you resize a stood vector
you didn't give it the value that should
be
constructed it default constructs
whatever the type is that is on the
vector
so thrust will
do that for you because that's what the
semantics of the vector are
now that may be
something you don't want to have happen
in which case you just could just use
cuda malloc yeah okay right if you don't
you don't care if the memory is
initialized
you can
just use cuda malloc because that's what
it's going to give you is uninitialized
memory
yeah that makes sense thanks
um
okay so
using
cuda from cmake in a modern cmake
works really great i i you know
all i had to do was
make sure that um i had installed the
cuda toolkit
after i had installed whatever compiler
i wanted to use
because on windows
and i believe this is windows only
on windows
uh the cuda toolkit sprinkles in a
little cuda integration
into the compiler
into visual studio
so that when you run cmake it can
automatically locate the mvcc
cuda compiler
and it can locate
all the binary tools that it needs to
run as part of the build process because
remember
cuda language support and cmake
as long as you have 3.8 or later which
3.8 is really quite old at this point
um built in there so when
you configure with cmake we can in fact
we can take a look
at it
i don't think i have my configure output
handy
but
in my top level cmake all i mean i i did
this but even saying that i was using
cuda
was you know not necessarily required
and this
fine package that i did that was just so
i could get
um
the cuda run time that i link against
but if i was
not necessarily needing to do that then
i guess that's not true you always need
to link against the cue to run time if
you're using any of the cuda runtime
functions so that just gave me a nice
uh imported target for the cuda runtime
but i don't need it to compile a cuda
file i don't need to find the toolkit in
order to compile it cuda file the
cmake's cuda language support
took care of that as long as
like i installed visual studio 2019
after i had installed the cuda toolkit
so at first it didn't work it said it
couldn't find nvcc
but i reinstalled the cuda toolkit
and then it was fixed so it it was
really easy
i think
linking to coda rt shouldn't uh sorry
kuda run time shouldn't be needed
because it will be compiled with nvcc
under the hood right
uh that that used to be the case when it
couldn't recognize kuda as official what
we can find out
yeah
all i gotta do is go over here i mean i
work on linux that might be the only
difference
yay my visual studio
keyboard shortcut is bound to something
in webex all right let's do it this way
uh so it
did correctly
link
you can't see it
until i do this
but it
it rebuilt
oops i get i'm so used to keyboard
shortcuts and
webex isn't liking it
so it it it rebuilt the this sample
without linking against the cuda rt
so i think you're right that the com the
mvcc compiler
is doing that
for you
but suppose i was writing some kind of
code
that
didn't launch any kernels but still
interacted with cuda
and then it wouldn't be compiled with
mvcc because it would just be cpp files
then i would need to link against the
cuda runtime
um
so the the cuda language support makes
it really easy to use from cmake and if
you want to
get access to
um
the headers you know in things like
thrusts and stuff like that you can do
find cuda toolkit to get the location of
your toolkit and then
do any additional fine file stuff
necessary to locate particular things
create imported targets as a matter of
convenience
there is a
this policy uh cmp0104
which you might get a um
warning about when you configure and it
has to do with
when we discussed before that your cuda
code when compiled to the device it can
either can be compiled to
a version of ptx a version list ptx or
it can be compiled towards a specific
gpu architecture
in the form of kubin's
they change the policy saying
um
how
the set of default architectures that
are targeted by the compiler into a
kubin form are specified and
it'll complain at you that you haven't
set this variable if you haven't
adjusted the policy setting
uh so
in the chat there's another question
here it says is it possible to run
cuda in a hyper vvm
so um
and another uh comment from here says
you know it can work in wsl which is
windows subsystem
uh
it's the windows
linux subsystem right it's the windows
subsystem for linux that's what it is
wso
this is basically running real linux
inside windows
with a minimal amount of
vm trampolining in between
now
they've made some
effort in making cuda visible from wsl
and
that's what mehir is commenting on
and the question is can you run it in
other vms like in you know vmware or
whatnot
and i believe
it's always been possible
but the gpu itself is not virtualized
that it is what's called pci passthrough
where a pci device on the host
is made visible as a pci device in the
guest
and
that means you can access the gpu
from the vm
provided you've enabled this uh you know
pci bridge functionality
but what it means is um
because the access is not virtualized
means the virtual machines can interfere
with each other because they're all
sharing the same physical gpu the gpu is
not virtualized
and
they can also interfere with the host
because again the access is not
virtualized
um so the that policy will be annoying
just just you know it's harmless but
like most of those policy warnings are
but if you don't like seeing that output
you can
set it appropriately um the cuda toolkit
documentation from which i have lifted
examples and
figures
is really
pretty well written there's a
programming guide which is where i
recommend you start
and from the programming guide
you will learn about various uh
scenarios
and how to
achieve them with cuda and then from
there you can drill into the reference
for all the particular functions in
order in their arguments
um
thrust
is also documented in the toolkit
but they have um doxygen generated
documentation up on github
so that um
the the thrust documentation that's in
the toolkit gives a general overview of
thrust kind of like i've done
and if you want to drill deeper then
it's it's you know it's off to the
doxygen for you
which you can find on github thrust is
maintained on github and
the version on github may be newer than
what's in whatever the current cuda sdk
is although the cuda sdk releases had a
pretty good cadence
so you won't you're not as long as
you're staying up to date on the cuda
sdk releases you're not likely to lag
very far behind
uh there's also a
a huge chunk of as you might imagine of
nvidia's website dedicated to developers
and that's the nvidia developer zone
um i believe you have to register
to join
um
so uh depending on how you feel about
giving your email address out you know
just make a
a gmail account or whatever like that if
that's how you prefer to do things
um
i don't i mean i've been registered on
there um and i i don't recall
you know getting a lot of you know
spammy type messages but i usually the
first thing i do after i register is go
and turn off all email notifications
myself but
you know whatever works for you guys
um there's also an annual
technology conference
and i believe
all the past presentations are online
um you can register for it's been
virtual the past two years i believe
and uh it's likely to be virtual again
because things are crazy
uh registration is free so you know you
don't have to
be
somebody spending millions of dollars on
nvidia cards for your data center to be
somebody that can get the information at
that conference also as we saw cuda
having been introduced in 2006 so that's
14 15 years ago
there's obviously a huge online
community around cuda so asking
questions on stack overflow or in the
video developer forums or wherever you
go to get your programmer answers
there's likely to be lots of other
people who have done this before you and
can help you out
are there any further questions before
we wrap things up
either by audio or by chat if you want
to do audio make sure you unmute
yourself first
okay uh it seems there are no questions
so we will
end it there